et 150 000 trajets par jour à Los Angeles.
Pour replacer cela dans son contexte,
Uber à Los Angeles
fait aujourd'hui 157 000 trajets par jour...
100 ans plus tard.
Voici des conducteurs de tram,
le moyen de transport ayant le monopole à l'époque.
Ils n'étaient clairement pas contents de l'avancée spectaculaire du jitney.
Ils se sont donc mis au travail
et ont été dans des villes dans tout le pays
pour mettre en place des lois pour freiner la croissance du jitney.
Il y avait tous types de réglementations.
Il y avait des licences, souvent chères.
Dans certaines villes,
les jitneys
devaient être dans le véhicule 16h par jour.
Dans d'autres villes,
il fallait deux conducteurs par jitney.
Mais il y avait une règlementation très intéressante :
il devait y avoir une lumière pour la banquette arrière
dans chaque jitney --
pour éviter que les gens ne s'embrassent à l'arrière.
(Rires)
Et que s'est-il donc passé ?
En une année, cela s'était envolé.
Mais, en 1919, le jitney était si règlementé qu'il a arrêté d'exister.
C'est malheureux...
Parce que, quand on ne peut pas partager une voiture, il faut en posséder une.
La possession de voiture est montée en flèche
et il n'est pas étonnant qu'en 2007,
il y avait aux États-Unis une voiture par homme, femme et enfant.
Et ce phénomène s'est mondialement répandu.
En 2011, en Chine,
il y avait plus de vente de voitures qu'aux États-Unis.
Cette propriété privée a un coût public.
Aux États-Unis, nous dépensons chaque année 7 milliards d'heures,
gâchées, dans les bouchons.
160 milliards de dollars en productivité perdue,
en étant dans les bouchons,
et un cinquième de notre empreinte carbone
est rejeté par nos voitures.
Ce n'est cependant que 4% de notre problème.
Parce qu'en ayant notre propre voiture,
96% du temps cette voiture est immobile.
Et jusqu'à 30% de notre terrain et de notre espace
sont utilisés à entreposer ces morceaux de ferraille.
Nous avons même des immeubles pour voitures.
C'est le monde dans lequel nous vivons aujourd'hui.
Les villes gèrent ce problème depuis des dizaines d'années.
Ce sont les transports publics.
Et même dans une ville comme New York,
l'une des villes les plus densément peuplées
et l'un des systèmes de transport public les plus sophistiqués du monde,
il y a encore 2,5 millions de voitures qui traversent ces ponts chaque jour.
Pourquoi ?
Car les transports publics n'ont pas encore réussi
à aller au seuil de chez tout le monde.
Et donc, de retour à San Francisco où j'habite,
la situation est bien pire,
la pire à travers le monde.
Au début d'Uber en 2010,
nous voulions seulement appuyer sur un bouton et être conduits.
Nous n'avions pas de grandes ambitions.
Mais il s'avère
que beaucoup de personnes voulaient cela.
Finalement, nous avons commencé à voir beaucoup de trajets dupliqués.
Nous voyions beaucoup de personnes
appuyant sur le même bouton au même instant
et allant au même endroit.
Nous avons commencé à réfléchir
à la façon dont nous pouvions réunir ces deux trajets en un seul.
Car si nous y arrivions, le trajet serait beaucoup moins cher --
jusqu'à 50% moins cher --
et bien sûr, pour la ville,
c'étaient plus de personnes et moins de voitures.
La question principale était :
est-ce que cela fonctionnerait ?
Pourriez-vous avoir un trajet moins cher,
assez pour que les gens acceptent de partager une voiture ?
La réponse, heureusement, est un oui retentissant.
A San Francisco,
avant uberPOOl, nous avions --
chacun prenait sa voiture pour aller où bon lui semblait.
Les couleurs vives ce sont les endroits avec le plus de voitures.
Une fois que nous avons lancé uberPOOL,
vous voyez qu'il y a moins de couleurs vives.
Plus de personnes se déplaçant dans moins de voitures,
diminuant le nombre de voitures sur les routes.
Il semble qu'uberPool fonctionne.
Nous l'avons lancé à Los Angeles
il y a huit mois.
Depuis, nous avons fait diminuer les trajets de 12,7 millions de kilomètres
et ôté 1 400 tonnes de CO2 dans l'air.
Mais, concernant cela --
(Applaudissements)
Ma statistique préférée --
souvenez-vous, je viens de L.A.,
j'ai passé des années
assis derrière un volant à penser : « Comment arranger cela ? » --
ce que je préfère, c'est que 8 mois plus tard,
nous avons 100 000 nouvelles personnes chaque semaine qui font du covoiturage.
En Chine, tout est surdimensionné.
Nous faisons 15 millions de trajets par mois avec uberPOOL,
soit 500 000 par jour.
Et la croissance est exponentielle.
En fait, elle l'est ausi à L.A.
Quand je parle à mon équipe, nous ne disons pas :
« 100 000 personnes covoiturant chaque semaine, on a fini. »
mais : « Comment atteindre le million ? »
En Chine, cela pourrait être plusieurs millions.
UberPOOL est une excellente solution pour le covoiturage urbain.
Mais qu'en est-il des banlieues ?
Voici la rue où j'ai grandi, à Los Angeles.
C'est une banlieue du nom de Northridge,
et --
regardez ces boîtes aux lettres, elles vont très loin.
Et chaque matin à la même heure,
des voitures sortent des allées,
il n'y a souvent qu'une seule personne par voiture,
ils vont au travail, à leur lieu de travail.
Pour nous, la question est :
comment transformer
toutes ces voitures de banlieues --
et il y en a des dizaines de millions --
comment transformer ces voitures de banlieue en voitures partagées ?
Nous avons récemment lancé quelque chose à ce sujet : uberCOMMUTE.
Le matin, vous vous levez, vous préparez, buvez votre café,
entrez dans votre voiture
et allumez l'application Uber.
Et tout d'un coup,
vous devenez un conducteur Uber.
Et, en route, nous vous mettons en correspondance
avec un de vos voisins
et c'est vraiment génial.
Il n'y a qu'un petit problème...
Et c'est la règlementation.
30 centimes le kilomètre, qu'est-ce ?
C'est ce que le gouvernement américain
a déterminé comme étant le coût de possession d'une voiture au kilomètre.
Vous pouvez prendre n'importe qui aux États-Unis
et l'emmener où il veut aller au pied levé,
pour 30 centimes le kilomètre ou moins.
Mais si vous demandez 33 centimes par kilomètre, vous êtes un criminel.
Mais, et si pour 33 centimes le kilomètre,
nous avions un demi-million de personnes en plus à covoiturer à Los Angeles ?
Et si à 33 centimes par kilomètre,
nous avions 50 millions de personnes covoiturant au États-Unis ?
Si nous le pouvions,
c'est évidemment une chose que nous devrions faire.
Et ça nous ramène à la leçon sur le jitney.
Si en 1915 cela démarrait bien,
imaginez sans les règlementations qui ont été mises en place,
si cela avait pu continuer.
A quel point nos villes seraient-elles différentes ?
Aurions-nous des parcs à la place des parkings ?
Nous avons laissé passé cette chance.
Mais la technologie nous offre une seconde chance.
Je suis aussi excité que n'importe qui au sujet des voitures sans conducteur,
mais devons-nous attendre 5, 10 ou même 20 ans
pour faire de nos nouvelles villes une réalité ?
Avec la technologie aujourd'hui dans nos poches,
et des lois vraiment intelligentes,
nous pourrions transformer chaque voiture en une voiture partagée,
et nous pourrions reconquérir nos villes dès aujourd'hui.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson : Travis, merci.
Travis Kalanick : Merci.
CA : L'entreprise que vous avez fondée est absolument stupéfiante.
Vous n'avez parlé que d'une petite partie --
une partie puissante --
l'idée de transformer les voitures en transports publics ainsi,
c'est cool.
Mais j'ai quelques questions,
car je sais que les gens se les posent.
Tout d'abord, je crois que c'était la semaine dernière,
j'ai allumé mon téléphone et essayé de réserver un Uber
mais n'ai pas réussi à trouver l'application.
Vous avez fait une refonte radicale, audacieuse et courageuse.
TK : En effet.
CA : Comment ça s'est passé ?
D'autres personnes n'ont-elles pas trouvé l'application ?
Allez-vous convaincre avec cette refonte ?
TK : Pour commencer, je dois expliquer
ce que nous essayons d'accomplir.
Si vous connaissez un peu notre histoire,
cela fait sens.
Quand nous avons commencé,
on n'avait que des voitures noires.
Littéralement, vous appuyiez sur un bouton et obteniez une classe S.
Nous avions presque créé
une version immature d'une marque de luxe
qui ressemblait à un badge sur une voiture de luxe.
En nous internationalisant
et en passant des classes S aux pousse-pousse indiens,
il est devenu important pour nous
d'être plus accessibles,
d'être plus hyperlocaux,
de nous adapter aux villes dans lesquelles nous sommes
et c'est ce que vous voyez dans ces schémas colorés.
D'être plus iconique,
parce qu'un U ne veut rien dire à Sanskrit,
et U ne veut rien dire en mandarin.
C'était un des enjeux.
La première fois que vous sortez quelque chose comme cela,
vous mains sont moites,
vous avez --
vous êtes un peu inquiet.
Nous avons vu beaucoup de personnes --
au début, nous voyions plus de personnes lançant l'application
parce qu'elles étaient curieuses de voir ce qu'elles verraient en l'ouvrant.
Les nombres étaient un peu plus élevés que ce que nous attendions.
CA : C'est cool.
Maintenant, je dirais que vous êtes une sorte d'énigme.
Vos supporteurs et investisseurs, qui sont avec vous depuis le début,
pensent que la seule chance
de prendre la puissance, les intérêts ancrés
de l'industrie des taxis
est d'avoir un compétiteur féroce et impitoyable,
ce que vous avez prouvé être.
Certains pensent que vous avez presque été trop loin avec cette culture,
et vous savez -- il y a un ou deux ans
il y avait une grande controverse, les femmes étaient mécontentes.
Comment cela se passait-il dans l'entreprise à cette époque ?
Avez-vous remarqué une baisse dans les affaires ?
Avez-vous appris à ce sujet ?
TK : Je pense --
je suis entrepreneur depuis le lycée
et il y a --
de plusieurs façons, un entrepreneur a des moments difficiles
et pour nous,
c'était il y a environ un an et demi,
c'était difficile pour nous aussi.
A l'intérieur, nous avions l'impression --
je pense que finalement,
nous avions l'impression d'être de bonnes personnes faisant un bon travail,
mais de l’extérieur, ce n'était pas évident.
Nous avions beaucoup à faire
pour --
Nous étions passés d'une très petite entreprise --
littéralement, il y a deux ans et demi,
il y avait 400 employés,
aujourd'hui il y en a 6 500.
Quand vous vivez cette croissance,
vous devez cimenter vos valeurs culturelles
et toujours en parler.
Et s'assurer que les gens s'interrogent toujours :
« Sommes-nous de bonnes personnes faisant un bon travail ? »
Si la réponse est oui,
vous devez ensuite vous assurer de raconter votre histoire.
Nous avons appris beaucoup de leçons,
mais nous en sommes sortis plus forts.
Mais c'était une période difficile.
CA : J'ai l'impression que quoi que vous fassiez,
vous avez des personnes qui vous posent des difficultés.
Certains conducteurs Uber à New York et ailleurs
sont en colère parce que vous avez changé la commission
et qu'ils disent pouvoir à peine se permettre de les payer.
Comment --
vous avez dit avoir commencé ainsi --
le côté cool d'appuyer sur un bouton et de convoquer une voiture.
Ce truc a démarré,
au point où vous affectez toute l'économie mondiale.
Vous êtes forcé d'être, que vous le vouliez ou non,
un visionnaire mondial qui change le monde.
Qui êtes-vous ?
Voulez-vous cela ?
Êtes-vous prêt à assumer cela et à faire ce qu'il faut ?
TK : Il y a plusieurs choses sous cette question.
(Rires)
La première chose, la tarification --
gardez-le en tête.
UberX, quand nous avons démarré,
était 10% ou 15% moins cher que nos produits de voitures noires.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est la moitié du prix d'un taxi dans beaucoup de villes.
Nous avons les données qui montrent
que les conducteurs gagnent plus d'argent par heure que les chauffeurs de taxis.
Quand le prix diminue,
les gens vont probablement prendre Uber
à plus de moments de la journée qu'ils ne l'auraient fait autrement,
et ils vont plus probablement l'utiliser dans plus d'endroits.
Pour un conducteur, cela signifie que dès qu'il dépose quelqu'un,
il a plus de chances de récupérer quelqu'un d'autre.
Cela signifie plus de trajets par heure,
plus de minutes productives par heure
et donc les gains augmentent.
Il y a des villes où nous avons baissé les prix cinq ou six fois
puis ces prix ont réaugmenté.
Même à New York --
nous avons un blog appelé « 4 septembres »
qui compare les gains
septembre après septembre après septembre.
Chaque année le même mois.
Et nous voyons les bénéfices augmenter
alors que les prix diminuent.
Il y a un prix parfait -- vous ne pouvez pas constamment diminuer.
Dans les lieux où nous diminuons les prix
mais où les bénéfices n'augmentent pas,
nous ré-augmentons les prix.
Cela répond à la première partie.
Pour l'énigme et tout le reste --
je suis le genre d'entrepreneur
que la résolution de problèmes excite.
J'aime dire que c'est comme être un professeur de maths.
Un professeur de maths n'ayant pas de problèmes difficiles à résoudre,
est un professeur de maths triste.
Chez Uber, nous aimons les problèmes difficiles
et les résoudre nous excite.
Mais pas n'importe quel problème de maths,
nous voulons les plus difficiles que l'on puisse trouver
et qui, s'ils sont résolus,
vont impressionner.
CA : Dans quelques années,
disons 5 ans, je ne sais pas quand --
vous sortez vos incroyables voitures sans conducteur,
probablement moins cher que l'on ne paye pour un trajet Uber.
Que dites-vous à votre armée actuelle de plus d'un million de conducteurs ?
TK : Redites cela -- quand ?
CA : Quand les voitures sans conducteur arriveront --
TK : Bien sûr. Désolé.
CA : Que dites-vous à un conducteur ?
TK : Je pense qu'il faut commencer par --
cela va probablement prendre plus de temps
que ce que disent certains médias.
Premièrement.
Ensuite, cela va également prendre --
il y aura une longue transition.
Les voitures fonctionneront dans certains endroits uniquement.
Pour nous, le défi est intéressant.
Parce que --
Google a investi depuis 2007,
Tesla va le faire, Apple va le faire,
les constructeurs vont le faire.
C'est un monde qui va exister, et pour une bonne raison.
Chaque année, un million de personnes meurent en voiture.
Et nous avons déjà parlé des milliards ou trilliards d'heures dans le monde
que les gens passent assis en voiture, à conduire, frustrés et anxieux.
Pensez à l'amélioration de la qualité de vie
quand vous rendez leur temps aux personnes
et qu'il n'y a plus d'anxiété.
Il y a beaucoup de positif.
Nous le voyons comme un défi,
mais pour une direction otpimiste
où au lieu de résister
à la technologie,
comme l'industrie des taxis ou des bus,
nous devons l'embrasser ou faire partie du futur.
Mais comment diriger de façon optimiste ?
Pouvons-nous créer des partenariats avec les villes ?
Pouvons-nous avoir des systèmes éducatifs, des formations
pour cette période de transition ?
Cela prendra plus de temps que ce que nous pensons,
en particulier pour la transition.
Mais c'est un monde qui va exister
et qui sera un monde meilleur.
CA : Travis, ce que vous contruisez est incroyable
et je vous suis extrêmement reconnaissant d'être venu à TED et d'avoir partagé.
Merci beaucoup. TK : Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)